Eh, normalmente cuando hablamos de decisiones clínicas en medicina,
existe, digamos, esta expectativa de precisión que es casi quirúrgica, o
sea, hay una fractura evidente, la radiografía te muestra esa línea blanca dentada
con absoluta claridad, y quien evalúe la imagen simplemente señala y dice,
bueno, ahí está el problema estructural, esta es la placa de titanio exacta que
necesitamos.
Claro. Y esa ilusión de precisión absoluta nos hace muchísimo daño en otras áreas.
Totalmente.
Especialmente en la cardiología preventiva, porque la presión arterial no es un
hueso roto. A ver, es una variable super dinámica.
Es dinámica y el problema es que, en la práctica diaria, pues buscamos
respuestas binarias donde simplemente no existen.
Queremos que la enfermedad esté presente o ausente, o que el fármaco funcione
o no funcione.
Ajá, pero cuando entramos al terreno del manejo inicial de la
hipertensión arterial esencial, abandonamos esa comodidad de la
radiografía, ¿no? Entramos en un terreno bastante pantanoso.
O sea, caminar a ciegas en un campo minado de opciones farmacológicas
es prácticamente la norma.
Sobre todo cuando no hay comorbilidades que marquen el rumbo.
Y bueno, con eso en mente, es un placer iniciar este análisis a
fondo sobre el documento de selección de farmacosemiotics.
El SEL0024.
Un documento fascinante, por cierto.
Muy fascinante.
El escenario clínico que tenemos sobre la mesa es sumamente específico, pero
a la vez es el pan de cada día en cualquier consultorio de atención primaria
o de medicina interna.
Sí, estamos hablando de adultos con hipertensión arterial esencial que van a
iniciar tratamiento farmacológico en monoterapia.
Exacto, monoterapia.
Y el detalle que define absolutamente todo este análisis es la ausencia
de indicaciones imperiosas.
¿Qué es clave?
Es clave. O sea, hablamos de un paciente sin insuficiencia cardíaca, con fracción
de eyección reducida, sin enfermedad renal crónica proteinúrica,
sin diabetes con albuminuria y sin riesgo de embarazo.
O sea, clínicamente hablando, es un lienzo en blanco.
Un lienzo en blanco, literal.
Y para ese lienzo, el documento SEL0024 presenta a
cuatro contendientes que, digamos, dominan la sección 12.3
de la lista modelo de medicamentos esenciales.
Hablamos de pesos pesados.
Los de siempre.
Los de siempre. La hidroclorotiazida, el amlodipino, el
enalapril y el losartán.
Cuatro pilares de la prescripción a nivel mundial.
Y además, todos genéricos, todos orales.
Y la mayoría de una sola toma diaria, claro, con la excepción del enalapril, que
bueno, por su vida media a veces requiere dosificación cada 12 horas.
Y aquí es donde la ciencia de los datos nos lanza una curva que de verdad
desorienta un poco.
Porque cuando observamos las comparaciones directas de mayor peso
estadístico, la diferencia de estas cuatro clases en el desenlace de
mortalidad total es absolutamente indistinguible.
Empatan, es un empate total.
Empatan a cero.
O sea, si el único objetivo fuera mirar la mortalidad por cualquier causa al
cabo de 5 o 10 años, tirar un dardo con los ojos vendados a la lista de
estos cuatro medicamentos te daría exactamente el mismo resultado
estadístico.
Y ese justamente es el punto de partida del informe.
Si la mortalidad global no nos sirve de brújula, pues porque no discrimina
entre los candidatos, el desempate tiene que buscarse obligatoriamente en
otro nivel.
El propósito de este análisis no es recitarte una tabla de nombres
con dosis, sino desgranar el criterio decisorio exacto.
O sea, ¿por qué gana el que gana?
Y para eso tenemos que evaluar la prevención de desenlaces duros
específicos, ¿no?
Exactamente. Insuficiencia cardíaca, enfermedad vascular
cerebral o EVC y eventos cardiovasculares totales.
Y bueno, de manera crucial, que a veces se nos olvida, debemos mirar las tasas de
abandono por efectos adversos.
Ok, vamos a desempacar esto porque a mí me parece que estamos frente a una
paradoja monumental. O sea, si los cuatro fármacos empatan a
cero en el partido de la mortalidad, ¿cómo definimos quién gana?
Es complejo.
Es como intentar elegir, digamos, el mejor bisturí
basándonos únicamente en el brillo del acero.
Me gusta esa analogía.
A ver, todos son de metal, todos cortan, todos brillan bajo
la luz del quirófano. La diferencia real tiene que estar en cómo se comportan
frente a la fricción prolongada.
Totalmente de acuerdo.
Entonces, pasemos al campo de batalla de la eficacia.
¿Qué nos dicen los datos sobre esos desenlaces duros específicos que
mencionas?
Bueno, para estructurar este campo de batalla, el documento se apoya en una
base de evidencia gigantesca. Primero tenemos la revisión Cochrane de
comparaciones directas de primera línea, bajo el PMID 37439548.
Pero el motor estadístico real de esa revisión, y digamos de
toda esta discusión, es el monumental ensayo ALLHAT.
Claro, el clásico ALLHAT.
El clásico, registrado con el PMID
12479763.
Y a ver, antes de dar cifras, creo que hay que entender qué es ALLHAT.
Sí, por favor.
Fue un ensayo clínico aleatorizado, doble ciego, financiado por el Instituto
Nacional del Corazón,
Los Pulmones y la Sangre allá en Estados Unidos,
y fue diseñado específicamente para ver si los fármacos más nuevos y costosos,
como los antagonistas del calcio o los inhibidores de la enzima convertidora de
angiotensina,
Exacto. Querían ver si esos eran superiores al viejo y súper
barato diurético en la prevención de enfermedad coronaria fatal o infarto
no fatal.
¿Y la regla de oro que emerge de ahí?
O sea, cambia toda la perspectiva.
Por completo. La regla es que el ganador de esta contienda no es
el que hace algo de manera extraordinariamente mejor, sino el que
matemáticamente se niega a perder en ninguna comparación directa.
O sea, el que logra mantenerse invicto.
Exacto, el invicto.
A ver, pongamos a prueba esa teoría.
Vamos a subir al ring a la hidroclorotiazida, que aquí está
representando a los diuréticos tiazídicos,
frente al amlodipino, que es el campeón indiscutible de los antagonistas
del calcio dihidropiridínicos.
Bueno, una pequeña aclaración primero.
En ALLHAT, la representación de la clase tiazídica se hizo con
clortalidona.
Claro, es verdad.
Lo cual es una limitación aceptada del informe porque, a ver, estamos leyendo la
evidencia de clase extrapolando ligeramente, pero el impacto
fisiológico es, pues, equiparable en este contexto.
Sí, lo asumimos como válido para el análisis de clase.
Exacto. Entonces, cuando comparamos el antagonista del calcio frente al
diurético, hay un empate técnico en el desenlace coronario primario a los seis
años.
Las tasas son 11,3% para el amlodipino frente a 11,5%
para el diurético.
O sea, prácticamente un calco.
Es lo mismo.
Un calco. Y tampoco hay diferencia en la mortalidad total.
Pero yo intuyo que ahí no termina la historia, ¿verdad?
Porque si no, seguiríamos en empate y no tendríamos ganador.
Pues no, la historia da un giro dramático cuando miramos la insuficiencia cardíaca.
Ahí el amlodipino pierde, pero rotundamente, en el desarrollo de
insuficiencia cardíaca incidente a seis años.
¿Rotundamente? A ver, dame los números.
Estamos hablando de una incidencia de 10,2% para el amlodipino,
frente a un 7,7% para el diurético.
Espera. A ver, vamos a traducir eso para quien nos escucha de camino a la
consulta, porque el cerebro tiende a ignorar porcentajes de un solo dígito y
suenan chiquitos.
Sí, suenan a poco.
Un 10,2% frente a un 7,7% nos da
un riesgo relativo de 1,38, con un intervalo de
confianza del 95% que va de 1,25 a 1,52.
O sea, eso significa casi un 40% más de riesgo
relativo de desarrollar insuficiencia cardíaca.
Es muchísimo.
Es una barbaridad.
En términos poblacionales, considerando que una fracción enorme de los
adultos padece hipertensión, elegir la molécula equivocada en la
primera consulta equivale a enviar a miles de personas a las salas de
urgencias, con disnea, con ortopnea y los pulmones llenos
de líquido en los próximos seis años.
Sí, es un golpe estadístico devastador.
Literalmente eso saca al amlodipino del primer puesto de manera instantánea.
¡Claro que sí!
Ahora, si el amlodipino cae por la insuficiencia cardíaca, la lógica
clínica, lo que nos enseñan en la escuela de medicina, nos diría que un
inhibidor de la enzima convertidora de angiotensina, un IECA, como el
enalapril, debería ser el campeón indiscutible.
Pues claro, porque el bloqueo del eje renina-angiotensina es el estándar de
oro para proteger el corazón. Debería aplastar a la tiazida.
Ese es el razonamiento fisiopatológico clásico que todos hacemos.
Ajá, pero los datos de ALLHAT nos dan una bofetada de realidad
tremenda aquí.
A ver.
En este brazo, la clase de los IECA estuvo representada por el lisinopril,
y frente al diurético, nuevamente vemos un empate en el desenlace
coronario primario con un riesgo relativo de 0.99, o sea,
idénticos.
Ok, empatan ahí. ¿Pero dónde falla?
El IECA falla en otros frentes.
Presenta una mayor incidencia de enfermedad vascular cerebral, de EVC.
Estamos hablando de 6.3% frente a 5.6%,
lo que nos arroja un riesgo relativo de 1.15.
¡Guau! ¿Más riesgo de EVC?
Y no solo eso. También presenta más insuficiencia cardíaca, con un riesgo
relativo de 1.19, y más enfermedad cardiovascular combinada,
con un riesgo relativo de 1.10.
Oye, espera, hay que hacer un apunte súper crítico aquí sobre
esa diferencia en EVC, porque recuerdo que los pacientes asignados al IECA
en ALLHAT tenían en promedio una presión arterial sistólica de unos
2 milímetros de mercurio más alta que los del grupo del diurético.
Sí, es cierto.
O sea, el control tensional fue ligeramente inferior.
Y a ver, sabemos perfectamente que el riesgo de EVC es exquisitamente
sensible a cambios milimétricos en la presión sistólica.
Así que, yo me pregunto, ¿parte de ese fracaso podría ser simplemente un control
de presión menos estricto y no necesariamente un fallo intrínseco de la
molécula del IECA?
Es una salvedad metodológica excelente.
Y de hecho, el documento la reconoce explícitamente.
Ah, ok.
Sin embargo, en la medicina basada en evidencias, evaluamos los resultados del
mundo real.
Y el ensayo demostró que, al intentar manejar a los pacientes con el IECA como base
inicial, los resultados cardiovasculares duros fueron simplemente inferiores.
Ya, la intención de tratar.
Exacto. Si ponemos todos los números sobre la mesa, la superioridad del diurético
tiazídico en términos absolutos parece pequeña.
O sea, oscila entre 0.6 y 1.2 puntos porcentuales de diferencia
frente a los competidores.
Parece poco.
Parece, pero la conclusión estadística es implacable.
La hidroclorotiazida es la única molécula de este selecto grupo
que se mantiene invicta.
No pierde.
No pierde contra el amlodipino, no pierde contra el IECA.
Es, digamos, el único muro que no cede.
A ver, frena un momento.
Dime.
Entiendo la victoria matemática en eficacia, me queda clarísimo.
Pero como clínica, tengo que jugar al abogado del diablo.
Adelante.
Porque cualquier especialista razonable que ejerza en la práctica de todos los
días va a ver un problema gigantesco aquí.
Me estás pidiendo que mañana en mi clínica acepte que un fármaco de los años
50, con un perfil metabólico que es notoriamente sucio, es
mi mejor opción.
Sucio sí, esa es la palabra que siempre usan.
Es que lo es. Sabemos que la hidroclorotiazida exige un control
analítico riguroso.
Esto bloquea el cotransportador sodio-cloro en el túbulo contorneado distal
y eso incrementa la entrega de sodio al túbulo colector.
¿Y qué pasa? Fomenta el intercambio por potasio.
Claro, hipopotasemia.
El resultado directo es hipopotasemia.
Y además, hay un riesgo súper real de hiponatremia, que en adultos
mayores te puede causar desde un letargo leve hasta convulsiones graves.
Sí, es un riesgo documentado.
Y ni hablar de la hiperuricemia que es dosis dependiente, porque compite con la
secreción de ácido úrico en el túbulo proximal.
Con todo este perfil adverso que está súper documentado en la información para
prescribir, seguramente los pacientes abandonan la tiazida muchísimo más que las
moléculas modernas.
Es lógico pensarlo.
Es que tienes que convencerme, porque recetar esto como primera línea hoy suena
casi a herejía médica.
Mira, te entiendo perfecto porque esa es la reacción instintiva de la gran mayoría.
Pero aquí es exactamente donde entramos en la paradoja de la seguridad y los
abandonos.
¿Paradoja?
Sí, porque la intuición clínica se equivoca de manera monumental en este punto.
El documento SEL0024 derriba este mito usando la
métrica más honesta y pragmática que tenemos,
que son los abandonos del tratamiento por efectos adversos.
Claro, el abandono real.
Porque, a ver, un efecto adverso en un papel de laboratorio impreso es una cosa,
pero la decisión de un paciente de tirar la pastilla a la basura y decir no vuelvo
a tomar esto,
Esa es la verdadera medida de la tolerancia en el mundo real.
¿Y qué dicen los datos ahí?
Los datos de la revisión Cochrane muestran, de forma súper contraintuitiva, que la
tiazida tiene menos abandonos que sus competidores directos.
Espera, ¿menos abandonos?
A pesar de la hipopotasemia, el riesgo de hiponatremia y la
hiperuricemia que acabo de mencionar.
A pesar de absolutamente todo ello.
¡Wow!
Vamos a las siglas, porque son de verdad reveladoras.
Frente al IECA, la tiazida provoca menos abandonos.
Estamos hablando de un 2,9% frente a un 3,9%.
O sea, un riesgo relativo de 0,73.
Exacto, con un intervalo de confianza de 0,64 a 0,84.
Esto se traduce en una reducción absoluta del abandono del 1%,
con una certeza de la evidencia moderada según la metodología GRADE.
Entonces estamos hablando de un 27% menos de riesgo relativo
de que el paciente abandone el tratamiento frente al IECA.
Así es.
Oye, para entender esto, creo que hay que ir a la fisiopatología, porque el
IECA no solo bloquea la conversión de angiotensina I en angiotensina II,
también bloquea la enzima que degrada las bradicininas.
Ahí está el detalle.
Y esas bradicininas se acumulan en el tracto respiratorio y te
causan una tos seca persistente que es súper molesta.
Literalmente no deja dormir al paciente y tampoco a su familia.
Y esa tos destruye la adherencia.
La aniquila por completo.
¿Y sabes qué pasa cuando enfrentamos a la tiazida contra el antagonista del calcio?
A ver, dímelo.
Pues los números también favorecen al diurético.
Los abandonos frente al amlodipino son de 6,2% frente a 7,6%.
¡Interesante!
Un riesgo relativo de 0,81 con un intervalo de confianza que va
de 0,75 a 0,88.
Hablamos de una reducción absoluta del 1,4%,
Aunque bueno, hay que decir que en este caso, la certeza de la evidencia
se califica como baja.
Me encanta cómo todo esto desafía nuestros sesgos clínicos.
O sea, a mí me gusta explicar esta paradoja con una analogía, digamos, del
automóvil.
A ver, cuéntame.
Las alteraciones metabólicas del diurético, como esos cambios en el ácido
úrico o la caída súper leve del potasio, son como la
luz de Check Engine en el tablero de tu auto.
Ajá.
Le preocupan inmensamente al mecánico, que en este caso es el médico que lee los
resultados del laboratorio, pero el conductor, el paciente, no siente
absolutamente nada. El coche sigue andando igual.
En cambio, los efectos adversos de los otros fármacos son como tener una llanta
ponchada.
Exacto, me parece brillante esa analogía.
El edema maleolar del amlodipino es la llanta ponchada
perfecta en este caso.
Claro.
Vamos a su mecanismo.
El amlodipino es un vasodilatador arterial muy potente, pero
carece de efectos sobre el lecho venoso.
Y esto crea un gradiente enorme, un aumento de presión hidrostática en
los capilares, que literalmente empuja el líquido hacia el espacio intersticial de
los tobillos.
O sea, ¿no es un fallo del corazón?
Para nada es pura plomería vascular.
Y fíjate que, curiosamente, este edema característico
sigue sin estar cuantificado de forma exacta con porcentajes
precisos en su información para prescribir, pero en la consulta es
imposible de ignorar.
Porque al paciente, seamos sinceros, no le importa la física de los
fluidos.
No le importa en lo absoluto.
Lo que le importa es que a media tarde no le entran los zapatos, que sienta pesadez
y que la hinchazón es visible y estéticamente le molesta.
Esa llanta ponchada del edema o la tos del enalapril son
efectos que se sienten y se padecen todos los días.
Pesan muchísimo más en la decisión humana de abandonar una terapia
preventiva que una hipopotasemia leve que, pues, solo existe en un
reporte impreso que ellos ni entienden.
Es una distinción súper brillante entre el daño de laboratorio y el daño
percibido.
Y ese, al final del día, es el gran triunfo de la tiazida.
No pierde la prevención de eventos catastróficos, que es lo vital.
Y además, no castiga la calidad de vida diaria del paciente lo suficiente
como para que abandone el barco.
Así es. Ahora, habiendo establecido esta victoria dual, hay que
preguntarse, ¿en qué escenario específico podría ganar otro de los candidatos?
Por ejemplo, ¿el amlodipino?
Bueno, pensemos en la conveniencia logística, ¿no?
A ver, todos son de administración oral, pero las exigencias satélite son bastante
diferentes.
Exacto. El terreno donde el amlodipino logra una victoria táctica súper
clara es en la ausencia de monitorización.
Pensemos en la hidroclorotiazida y en los bloqueadores del eje renina-angiotensina.
Las guías te exigen medir el potasio sérico y la creatinina para evaluar la función
renal a las dos o cuatro semanas de iniciar el tratamiento.
Y nuevamente cada vez que le ajusto la dosis al paciente.
Exactamente. El amlodipino es el único de los cuatro candidatos que no
exige este control analítico de laboratorio obligatorio.
O sea, no requiere ajuste por función renal en su fase inicial, ni una
monitorización metabólica tan estricta.
Y oye, esa es una ventaja enorme para ciertos contextos en nuestro
sistema de salud latinoamericano.
O sea, si un médico ejerce en una clínica rural donde no hay un laboratorio
disponible,
o si el paciente simplemente no tiene los recursos económicos o el tiempo para
ir a sacarse sangre de seguimiento,
pues el amlodipino se convierte en una alternativa primaria súper pragmática.
Es una cuestión de viabilidad de la intervención, puramente.
Y bueno, ya que tocamos el tema de los recursos económicos, el informe también
analiza el costo.
Ah, el factor costo.
La hidroclorotiazida es un genérico oral multifuente de una antigüedad
considerable, lo que, pues, lo posiciona sistemáticamente como el
antihipertensivo de menor costo de adquisición en cualquier tabla
comparativa que mires.
Sí, regalado.
Pero el documento de farmacosemiotics hace una aclaración muy crucial.
El costo no se utiliza aquí como un factor de desempate.
Claro, no gana por ser barato.
No.
Gana por ser el más eficaz, al no perder en los desenlaces duros y por tener
menos abandonos. El costo bajísimo es simplemente, no sé, un
refuerzo monumental a su victoria clínica.
Es una rareza fascinante en la medicina moderna.
Resulta que lo mejor es también lo más económico.
Es una lección de humildad gigantesca para el complejo industrial farmacéutico.
Totalmente. Pero, a ver, aquí es donde tengo que intervenir con fuerza y poner
sobre la mesa al elefante en la habitación.
A ver.
Pero, ¿qué pasa con el losartán?
Ay, ¿el losartán?
Es el rey de las prescripciones en incontables centros de salud.
Se venden millones de cajas al mes.
¿Me vas a decir que ignoremos a un antagonista del receptor de
angiotensina II, que es moderno y tiene una tolerabilidad legendaria,
por una pastilla de la década de los 50?
Bueno, el documento SEL0024 le da un
veredicto de reservado.
¿Cuál es la justificación para relegarlo así?
El losartán es el gran misterio estadístico en esta comparación específica.
Porque, y esto sorprende a muchos, carece de evidencia directa frente a los
otros tres candidatos en este análisis de primera línea para pacientes sin
complicaciones.
No hay evidencia directa.
Su juicio de eficacia en el documento es literalmente sin datos.
Cuando buscamos comparaciones directas contra la tiazida o el amlodipino en este
escenario clínico preciso.
Toda su reputación en hipertensión, o sea, su evidencia reina, proviene de un
estudio publicado bajo el PMID 11937178,
que es conocido mundialmente como el ensayo LIFE.
Pero a ver, el ensayo LIFE es un pilar absoluto de la cardiología, todos lo hemos
estudiado.
Lo es, sin duda. Pero hay que examinar su diseño metodológico con lupa.
En el estudio LIFE, el losartán se comparó únicamente frente al atenolol.
Y recordemos que el atenolol es un beta bloqueante que hoy en día ni siquiera
figura en esta tabla de candidatos de primera línea para hipertensión esencial
debido a su inferioridad comprobada.
Claro, o sea, el losartán le ganó a un fármaco que honestamente ya estaba de
salida.
Exacto. Y más importante aún, el estudio se realizó en una
población ultraespecífica.
Estamos hablando de pacientes de 55 a 80 años que ya
presentaban hipertrofia ventricular izquierda demostrada en el
electrocardiograma. Es decir, es una cohorte con daño de órgano blanco
preexistente.
Entonces, es científicamente inválido extrapolar esa victoria
a la población general.
En ese grupo súper estrecho, con hipertrofia, sí, el
losartán redujo el riesgo de EVC frente al atenolol, con un riesgo
relativo de 0.75.
Pero ojo aquí, no hubo diferencia significativa en mortalidad cardiovascular
ni en infarto agudo de miocardio.
Tal cual.
Y asumo que en términos de seguridad, frente a los otros tres candidatos de nuestra
lista, pues pasa exactamente lo mismo, ¿no?
Así es. Al no haber sido comparado directamente en ensayos amplios de
desenlaces clínicos contra la tiazida, el amlodipino o el enalapril,
su juicio de seguridad comparativa también queda sin datos en el marco estricto
de este informe de selección.
Lo que sí comparte de manera inequívoca con el enalapril es una
advertencia súper grave.
La toxicidad fetal.
Al bloquear el sistema renina-angiotensina,
que es fundamental para el desarrollo renal del feto, pues causan
oligohidramnios y malformaciones severas.
Por lo tanto, no podemos declarar a losartán como ganador empírico
para la población general con hipertensión esencial no complicada, simplemente
porque no se presentó a competir en el mismo torneo.
Es una excelente forma de verlo.
Ha estado jugando en una liga diferente.
Así es.
Entonces, hemos navegado a través de la eficacia y los desenlaces duros.
Hemos desmitificado la tolerancia revelando esos sorpresivos datos de
abandono. También, hemos reconocido la conveniencia logística del
amlodipino. Y, por supuesto, hemos puesto en su contexto real a
losartán. Yo creo que es el momento de estructurar la aplicación clínica.
Sí, la pregunta de oro.
¿Qué voy a hacer mañana por la mañana en la consulta?
Exacto.
Para quien tiene la responsabilidad de firmar la receta, la síntesis del
veredicto SEL0024 es incontrovertible.
El fármaco seleccionado para iniciar tratamiento farmacológico en el adulto
con hipertensión arterial esencial en monoterapia, repito, sin indicaciones
imperiosas, es la hidroclorotiazida.
Así es, y este veredicto viene condicionado a una perla clínica que es
fundamental y que altera toda la relación riesgo-beneficio.
Me refiero a la dosis.
Clave.
El informe especifica que la dosis de hidroclorotiazida debe
mantenerse estrictamente en el rango de 12,5 miligramos a 25 miligramos
al día. Esto se debe a la forma de su curva de respuesta
farmacodinámica.
Vamos a la fisiología de esa curva, que es de verdad fascinante.
La eficacia antihipertensiva de las tiazidas tiene un efecto
techo muy temprano.
Muy temprano.
Si prescribimos dosis por encima de los 25 miligramos, digamos que
damos 50 miligramos, la curva de reducción de la presión arterial se
aplana por completo. O sea, no hay ganancia tensional extra, la
presión no baja más, cero ganancia.
Sin embargo, la curva de toxicidad, esa pérdida de potasio, el
aumento del ácido úrico, todas las alteraciones metabólicas, esa curva
sigue subiendo de manera exponencial.
Al superar los 25 miligramos, adquieres todo el daño metabólico
sin ningún beneficio vascular que te lo justifique.
Dosis bajas, beneficios máximos.
Es así de simple.
Ahora, para estructurar el arsenal restante, debemos tener mucha
claridad sobre cuándo es el momento de utilizar las alternativas.
Porque, ojo, no desaparecen de las guías.
No, para nada, siguen ahí.
El amlodipino asume el rol de alternativa principal cuando el seguimiento con
pruebas de laboratorio no es viable, como decíamos antes, o cuando el paciente
desarrolló una intolerancia real a la tiazida.
Pero, siempre recordando ALLHAT, debe evitarse como primera opción si el
paciente presenta riesgo incipiente o historial de insuficiencia cardíaca.
Y en cuanto al eje renina-angiotensina, el enalapril pasa a ser
de elección primordial en el mismísimo instante en que aparece una indicación
imperiosa.
Exacto.
Si en los laboratorios de control o, no sé, en el seguimiento a los dos años,
el paciente desarrolla enfermedad renal crónica proteinúrica,
diabetes con albuminuria o disfunción ventricular izquierda,
pues el IECA se vuelve indispensable para modificar el curso de la enfermedad.
Cambia el escenario por completo.
Cambia. Fuera de esos escenarios imperiosos, es una
alternativa secundaria y siempre hay que estar vigilando la aparición de
la famosa tos mediada por bradicininas.
Totalmente de acuerdo. Finalmente, el losartán, a pesar de su popularidad
masiva, queda relegado en este documento a un uso reservado estrictamente
para los pacientes que encajen de forma precisa en el perfil del estudio LIFE.
O sea, pacientes donde documentamos hipertrofia ventricular izquierda en el
electrocardiograma.
Exacto, y también para aquellos pacientes que requieren imperiosamente
bloquear el eje renina-angiotensina, pero que desarrollan tos
intratable o angioedema con el uso del IECA.
Y bueno, como mencionamos antes, hay que subrayar con tinta roja
la contraindicación absoluta del enalapril y el losartán en cualquier
escenario de embarazo o deseo de gestación debido a la letalidad
fetal.
Este análisis de verdad nos demuestra que la medicina basada en la
evidencia requiere un nivel de escrutinio que va mucho más allá de leer
el abstract de un estudio o dejarse llevar por la inercia del hábito de
prescripción.
Sin duda.
Arrancamos este análisis a fondo hablando de cómo buscamos decisiones
limpias y binarias en la medicina, de cómo intentamos elegir el mejor
bisturí basándonos sólo en cómo brilla el metal bajo la luz de la lámpara,
ignorando cómo se desgasta con el uso.
Y la revisión profunda de la evidencia a menudo nos obliga a confrontar
nuestras propias costumbres clínicas.
Nos obliga a evaluar si ese temor que tenemos, que a veces es infundado a
un cambio de laboratorio asintomático, nos está alejando de la intervención clínica
que realmente salva vidas a largo plazo.
Yo estoy convencida de que esa es una reflexión vital para llevar a
la próxima guardia o consulta.
Para quienes nos escuchan, la próxima vez que esté enfrente a un paciente con
diagnóstico reciente de hipertensión arterial esencial sin complicaciones y la
inercia clínica o la presión de recetar la molécula más sofisticada y nueva
los empuje hacia una dirección diferente, vale la pena hacer una pausa.
Una pausa muy necesaria.
Vale la pena preguntarse si estamos ignorando al fármaco más
antiguo y, casualmente, al más accesible, simplemente por
un prejuicio metabólico.
Todo esto, a pesar de que los números duros demuestran que es el único que
matemáticamente se niega a perder en la prevención de la insuficiencia cardíaca,
el infarto y el EVC.
Y, sorprendentemente, es el tratamiento que los pacientes abandonan con
menor frecuencia en la vida real.
A veces, la herramienta más antigua del maletín médico sigue siendo
el bisturí más afilado y seguro.